in one of the internships I completed
before I started my career in Consulting
at McKinsey I managed after some time to
closely work together with the managing
director and other board members of this
company during my internship and I
realized during the weeks I was there
how puzzled many of the other employees
of that company were how I managed to do
that right why I was now suddenly
closely working together with the senior
leadership of this company but how did
that work how did I make that happen and
in the end of the day this was down to
my PowerPoints kids down to my skills in
slight writing and this is exactly the
topic I want to talk with you today
about in this video so welcome to New
coffee break here on my channel from
learning the place where I want to help
you to become successful in the first
years of your Korea most companies both
medium-sized companies but also large
companies use slides as a main means of
communication especially when they
communicate to external parties to Banks
to investors financial institutions but
maybe also customers important suppliers
now try to put yourself into the shoes
of a senior leader of such a company who
is currently preparing for such an
important meeting of course that person
wants to make sure that the document
that he or she creates to present is
spot on is perfect is meeting highest
Professional Standards go that being
said it is just the truth based on my
humble experience that in many of these
companies even on very large corporate
organizations that they are only very
very few people who are really good at
PowerPoint who are really good at
creating professional slide
presentations and in this fact there
lies a huge opportunity for you because
if you are a young professional in the
first years of your career you are
lacking the Deep domain knowledge you
will not be sought out usually as an
expert from inside the organization but
if you have this basic technical skill
of creating professional slide
presentations suddenly you might find
yourself in the position to not help
other people significantly higher up in
the chain of command and of course this
is not just busy work because suddenly
you find yourself getting exposure to
the senior leadership of the company
some you're involved in some of the high
stakes high priority projects or
initiatives that the company is
spearheading and in addition to that and
frankly this is something also only
really understood since I started the
YouTube channel in 2020 there's a huge
demand in the corporate world to upskill
their employees on slide writing skills
as well so this is something I have not
talked about too much here on the
channel but I'm actually quite regularly
doing corporate training sessions on
Communications and slide writing skills
if you would be interested to do
something like this as well for your
team I will leave some more information
including reviews from prior clients in
the video description be free to check
this out but my actual Purpose with this
video is to help you upskill yourself on
slide writing skills too because let's
be honest it can be quite challenging to
acquire this light writing knowledge by
yourself because usually in corporate
environments you don't really get the
feedback that you're getting if you're
working in forums like McKinsey BCG Bain
where every single slide that you create
every single page we more or less get
ripped apart right by our project lead
or your partners if they don't meet
hires Professional Standards so you need
someone who teaches these skills to you
and usually when I conduct these
sessions with corporate clients these
clients pay four to five digit sums for
these training programs depending on the
scope and the number of participants the
one want to enable you to develop these
skills at a fraction of the cost and
this is why over the last months I've
been very busy with finalizing the
communications and slight Writing
Academy this is the new firm learning
educational Flagship offering aiming to
teach you all the communications and
slide writing skills that you would
acquire after several years of working
at a firm such as McKinsey BCG or Bain
besides these topics on Communications
and slide writing it also includes
additional modules such as on problem
solving skills and also professional
Readiness there's also pretty packed
bonus pack for instance I partnered with
the former McKinsey partner who delivers
a session for you on sponsor and Mentor
networks how you can build sponsor
networks in your organization and while
this might be the full game changer and
really advancing your career I think
this module alone is very much worth
worth the investment of joining the
academy the academy is mainly based
around on-demand videos they're like
seven or eight hours of pure video
materials on top of that you have lots
of handouts and you also have Capstone
projects that allow you to really apply
all your learnings on practical projects
to advance your skills and there's also
a certificate that you will get from me
from from learning if you successfully
complete the academy so if you're
interested in this there's a link in the
video description allowing you to enroll
into the communications and slide
Writing Academy for all of you actively
following the channel laws included a
bonus code in the video description
allowing you to enroll at a discount so
this code will only be there available
for you during the launch period if
you're not watching this later and the
code is there no longer sorry for this
but I can promise you that the academy
is still very much worth your investment
as well I will add additional content to
the academy in the future which is also
why I'm planning to increase is the
price of the academy going forward so if
you want to lock in the current price
and still get access to Future updates
as well can only recommend you to enroll
right now whether you decide to join or
not I can only recommend you to actively
work on your slide writing skills and of
course have also lots of videos
available on this channel from learning
for free teaching some of the best tips
and practices to working on slide
presentations and of course I will also
continue creating content for free here
for you on the from Learning Channel I'd
appreciate it if you like this video for
the YouTube algorithm and also subscribe
to the channel to stay up to date on our
future slide writing content that you
can expect here my name is Heinrich big
thanks to all the members of from
learning I'm creating weekly videos here
on the channel see you again next week
until then all the best to you